what a dedicated totality when a
nine-digit did it Adele hi everybody
dorable all right okay hello how are you
mother I'm fine
you know how I call you mother so what
you're trying to do here I'm gonna make
Mokpo large nail yeah so uh I don't know
why I have this I have this little thing
and I haven't had a chance to use it yet
so uh it exists and it's a little
gyroscopically stable
no one cares I want to put this down for
now and just right there don't move
hello everybody my name is Mark Millar
and I'm here with my mom say hi hi I'm
maka flowers mom also you have her real
name that's my that's your real name
mama pliers mama I'm a plier yeah so she
is learning to do nails and she's really
good at it apparently like a I won't you
been going for month yeah let me get a
close-up on that this is my second five
oh I think I might be alive not to
second try five you send me tons of
pictures no no no but I'm in second
final oh oh oh oh I gotcha
Winky Winky Winky so um but you are
gonna do me the great honor of doing
these horrid nail gonna try make mock
life based on these workers flyer into
your provider martyr flyer I am yeah
maka fly Flyers face on his fingernails
my fingernails yeah that's funny I
practice all day so what is the first
step in doing anything well let me do
some little simple manicure okay
it's only been a month so I might forgot
few steps if there's a professional nail
technician they're on me oh I think you
just gave me a good boss and within this
one you don't need to apologize for
anything
you're already better than all of them
out there LTS not that good I don't know
if you're gonna be mom applier you have
to bombastically claim that you're
better than everybody even if you're not
I'll bet I learned it from you right
let's ah I'm gonna talk to you oh I
suppose what the heck is it I have to
make a room dear it hurts
oh oh oh goodness crowd I fit all right
that's enough
no no if you got a do it go ahead and do
it no I'm done Oh done already
dad I think I'm done yeah okay we're
gonna do a little piling I think mm-hmm
what if my nails to start bleeding
horribly from all this abuse then I need
a stuffing call 9-1-1 oh really
you'd be that extreme my culture to have
dangerous infection going into now male
oh that sounds terrible
so if you are good Nell Tikas Janice
wasn't a puncture or tear any of your
nails I didn't know that it was such a
dangerous job getting your nails done so
what is that we're just gonna make a
nail bed clean nice and clean for nail
polish okay okay this is kind of awkward
Fred you should sit here why how can I
sit there I'd be I'd be right in the way
that's why making your life a little
fatter yeah that's pretty much what I've
been doing since I got born right yeah
about three or four how much you weight
I'm well where why don't you tell them
you weight 10 pounds 3 ounces 10 pounds
3 ounces and also because I didn't know
any better
oh I went naturally no no a patron Oh
you know why why because I didn't know
anything about their a patrol I thought
everybody was just naturally oh I
thought you would have learned your
lesson by the time my brother was born
and when it came to me when the program
was a lot smaller by a lot small he was
still nine pounds no it was a movie
seven time no use my reminyl seven
that's what I've been told my whole life
he was not talking your father lies Oh
make him feel little nuff oh oh why
would he feel oh you're a big boy he's a
little less big so maybe there's a
revelation that like 27 years of my life
is unraveling because I that's the truth
your brother was seven pounds and he's
more tensely I was a big drift do you
have any embarrassing stories to tell
about me as a child and icing strike
yeah embarrassing stories about me as a
child
never your perfect breeze I don't think
that's true oh no never
oh it's the only thing you're too big to
be yeah you keep other than that luckily
cry uh-huh you always smile oh okay yeah
I smile and paint my pants but oh you
always smile happy oh that's nice
I was perfect baby I just I came into
this world saying hello everybody my
name is Baraka that's you thank you
seriously
yeah what about any toddler so perfect
always smiling yeah I think I take only
one day for potty training
oh one day I was a genius you know how
old were you when you stopped walking
how old five months what not walking
they might be lying but when you stand
up yeah August coffee table all right
don't take a step that was my muscle
whoa
hear that guys I was a strong baby
okay gone yeah smart - I bet right I
didn't know you were just like oh but I
know you a good baby good that's a good
baby right there that's a good
now let's plot what color is this green
flicky that looks nice your color nice
what are other things from when I was a
child should should everyone out there
oh well how I conceived you lessor story
well yeah I wasn't supposed to be so
Christmas time so nobody will believe
what I say I might they might say I'm
lying but it's true - totally I was
opposed to be born he was opposed no no
two different types of contraception
well after I had at your first my first
child which is Thomas I decided I'm not
gonna have another one that was so hard
so I was taking you know full cushion
and then one day out of blue I saw many
people develop this terrible headache
and I decide we'll see a gynecologist or
anything well because you are taking
birth control pills
they might cause you have a high
proportion so that's a device stop
taking birth control pill and used other
contraceptive I asked I was only 22 how
can I do I want to make sure I don't get
pregnant
well that's a such a thing as a condom
you can use condom and spa massage
that's why we use both guess what you're
either pregnant dad mom oh that was you
yeah I'm a miracle baby
or a curse there's a quick look at that
but the color oh nice yeah it's good
stuff
where's more more won't let's try
eyeballs that's very important well
supposedly expression eyeballs I'm ready
ooh I want to make sure it's perfect -
doctor I'll go this way
okay you make perfect perfect I need to
have polka dots this is super important
yeah if I don't if I mess this one I'm
gonna fire you
yeah you better not pay me I'm never
coming home
yeah you're not gonna be my next
customer I know you'll never get another
customer Oh high-stakes oh my god
yes let's pray for this to dot or I
needed to that you have a small maybe
lil bit wow I'm impressed
nice nailed it
yes pretty good that's pretty good
it's pretty good yeah they're right all
right that's nervous yeah your whole
career depended on those two guys yes oh
good I think you did good okay now we're
gonna put eyeballs but the way to later
and it's right little bit longer how
about some of this buddies come Rose I
brass I brought gotta be perfect
I'd be perfect it's like everything else
here got to be perfect yeah one mistake
you're done okay that's the high stakes
thing it's more stressful than five
minutes of tracks very crisp okay don't
don't give me one upside down I bro it
oh there oh that's good oh that's good
oh that's real good yeah it's good yeah
okay that's pretty good I gotta admit
that's pretty good okay one more thing
and I'm gonna try is your mustache I
don't have pink I'm gonna use where okay
all right Reds okay again whole career
is riding on this yeah I'm gonna use
this fine brush okay I'm ready
oh no okay listen it's very critical
[Music]
aha how many think that's pretty good
that's pretty good that's not bad hey
not bad not bad that's good thank you
that's how my hair I like it
I hey I'm for her yeah just a little
okay
oh that's cute as cute okay one last one
last one yeah your eyeball okay awesome
that's awesome you did it you got a
career ahead you can do it then a little
let it dry a little bit I'm gonna put
top coat oh that's lovely it's really
lovely
I ruined the other nails I've touched my
hand a bunch that's okay but uh this is
the messy part is the important this is
we just take care of like okay yeah
you've got dreams no I'm pretty sure I
miss few steps here but ah no no no best
I've ever seen probably the best in the
world if I had to imagine oh oh yeah the
best I've ever seen
I'm sorry little bill yeah then again
I've never seen anyone else do that
nails before so best I've ever seen it
yeah not bad for five minutes pretty
good I like it so anyway that this is my
mother not as many embarrassing stories
as I thought they were gonna be I
thought there are gonna be many more
embarrassing stories than that but maybe
when we play a video game together
you'll hear some more so thank you much
for being here
be on the lookout for a Sun Oaks beauty
parlor down the road no no no mom keep
pliers
have to get the market lighting there so
people know hockey players mom's needle
fell off well when you open your nail
salon I'm sure everybody's gonna want to
stop by yeah write your name on top all
right it's not just about my mama pliers
nails a lot oh I want to see fan art of
that that what its gonna look like when
people can you give it give us a little
like sketch a quick mspaint sketch of
the storefront and the lovely interior
and all that stuff and we'll get an idea
of what your dreams gonna come become
like in the future yeah that's my goal
oh yes my dream yeah you're making a lot
of progress for just doing it for a
month yeah anyway thank you oh yeah
Indy's and thank you everybody so much
for watching be on the lookout for the
game video very soon and as always we'll
see you in the next video bye bye
that's good that's very good that's good
really good